so I'm at the gym today and here's what
you guys who have never been in a men's
locker room needs to know and guys will
back me up on this there's a certain age
that men hid in the locker room you
already know I'm gonna say don't you do
where they decide [ __ ] I'm not
wearing clothes anymore
at about 65 dudes are like drinking and
drinking and drinking this is your
future don't look away from it
stare at it look at it because it's not
a great it's not no that's a [ __ ]
crystal ball look into you know what I
mean
so today I'm in the [ __ ] locker room
and this eight year old dudes walking on
the shower and he's got flip-flops on in
a towel over his shoulder so he had
found the [ __ ] towels everybody okay
and he was just flip flops towel over
the shoulder and just all nuts just like
here the hacky sack or something and
they were gray and looked like he was
dragging a [ __ ] wizard behind him I
was like what's going on and then I
tried to get out of there with my with
my dignity right I'm like I don't want
to see this anymore and I'm washing my
hands dude walks up to the counter
[ __ ] Captain Morgan posts it like
perhaps a hairdryer he's like
the old guys blew treasure knots is it
crazy and he's looking at me he's like
how's it going not that good anymore
dude like it is how how many guys in
here will back up that story for me it's
like it crazy right now let me ask you
isn't it where men are [ __ ]
disgusting let me ask you another
question
alright that sounds like that sounds
like sudha getting fingered at a Foo
Fighters concert but that's just where I
imagine that [ __ ] happens and the Foo
Fighters concert is like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know they took all the hair dryers
out of the bathroom at my gym because
the old dudes would just like do you
know what they'd rather when they drive
through they'd use that I can't hand
dryers now but it's so weird because
it's they're nuts just so long it's
almost like they're not attached to
their body so there are full arm's
length away from the hair and they're
like boom like they just found the
marble bag on the ground and they're
just drying it all [ __ ] crazy right
now look look all day like we all are
getting older Lange and I will tell you
like okay okay you know that we know I
did notice a little part of my body this
is like the thing that I noticed the
first thing I noticed I was getting a
little older okay okay okay my wife's
here so it's okay to tell this okay so
we're all well familiar with the term
[ __ ] right
yeah as you get older it's not as much
of a shot do you know any mate it's like
a slow like a slow drip do you know what
I mean like you used to come out like
this ya know just kind of goes
right I mean I could give you a facial
but it's gonna be like this
that seems aggressive I would never do
that
somebody
[Music]
[Music]